this video is sponsored by one of my
personal favorite Services rocket money
more on them after the reaction
[Music]
people what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation we are Marvel up
you can get this at reject Nation
shop.com by all of the we're wearing
everything everything totally got me
shirts for Christmas my God we are
actually wearing the brand what is
happening here must be a good one anyway
guys uh we're at the echo finale loved
episode 4 I think I for all of us is
that being our favorite of the four that
we had watched let's just see what
happens we all right let's see what
happens episode 5 I am very hopeful
right now as as I'm sure both all three
of us are I'm really uh dragging my
words here leave a like on this video
and while you're doing that tell us in
the comments what did you think of the
finale did it did it land well for you
did it meet your expectations yeah he's
trying X-Men or ech uh prepper thank you
for helping us head this down fly watch
secet with your own copy of echo
available for super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page thank you to all who have
joined just to watch Echo with us we
cover several things over there
exclusively with highlights and watch LS
included all right let's let's do
it ain't nothing bad going to happen
today it's the bird oh it's the bird to
come back for you Coy I got to know what
he is it's a woodpecker is it a
woodpecker this whole time it's Woody
Woodpecker it looks like he's woodpeck
all right no don't do it we like
him
a yeah how does it feel sorrow you feel
sad feel bad about it I think a lot of
the echo Fanboy has just gone away now
no longer like this show they just
killed a precious little woodpecker yeah
wonder who did
that learning lying you're a little
serial killer aren't you the violence
has always been in her yeah the we're
getting but I don't like it oh it's
quality CGI bird they got
there
yeah I've seen this
before you're just like your father
learning about
[Music]
consequences I do that when I hit golf
balls outside of the Burger King parking
line you can't do
this this
kinck hm
whoa like Morse code is that what the
bird has been doing this whole episode
the season if you speak woodpecker it
ruined the whole
plot
oh what the hell Maya you knew about
this [__] all this time this is how we
start to cross over the powers of the
Mystic to the day
wow all it takes is a
hashtag so it seems like when the mom
died this really separed a connection
she's probably the best most
compassionate caregiver role model in
all of her young life and also like a
power connection like from the through
the ancestry how am I oh so only five
riders for 30-minute episode okay great
good sign each wrot a
[Laughter]
sentence go away we're closed you're not
closed you're napping you old Billy go
hurana here I have to get to
work radiant is the sun shining out of
my let's
hump oh what can I do you for I know
it's been a while but I'm sewing
again I bought in a a sewing machine a
few years back I was just wondering
maybe you of course he kept it you old
softy been waiting for this
[Music]
dayoo it looks like my mom mom's old one
well when you brought it in I cleaned it
and boiled it I knew you'd come back for
it I just had to wait he's also
installed some upgrades yeah it's got an
interface its own AI it's made of
nanotechnology
now promise me will'll come back once in
a while for the
humping playing the long game if we
don't get a post credits humping I'll be
very mad yeah this is now my jet ski is
them
humping I'll get the door you twoo
better going to love that turn of phrase
hey hey they know it's PG-13 I got learn
tvma the show allowed to say hump I
learned those actors names the both of
them are are so terrific and they they
they're vets please let me help oh thank
you are they going to give us some type
of Hawkeye ending she's going to shoot
him in the other eye haven't seen you
were on before you here for the pow yes
people come from all over for our chalk
on Nai how I was is that right wonder
what that line used to be your necklace
it's American Sign Language it says I
love you oh uh you sign I try for my nie
I I just started I know those three
words I learned for my daughter she
passed on now I've lost someone who I
loved it's the kind of pain you never
quite get over I keep it up now for my
granddaughter his body language is
amazing he's like this clenched fist her
name is
Maya uh she just come in from
Basher headen
yeah everyone shut up Easter egg please
explain this ending to me what does it
mean tell me someone in
comics motorcycle two wheels Xavier
confirmed Jackal it's
Jackal feel like nothing's happening
with the rocks on world no it's just
going to be a keep throwing rocks on on
everything
here they could have done something
really cool with it with Thor but they
just there was a plot line right there
they
just it's a million dollar
contact oh yeah right over there is
General parking with Roger Two Moons if
you just head so uh I'm going to pack up
down by there so I can enjoy your
indigenous fair from AAR is he trying to
do an Irish accent now so if you're a
vendor though they should have given you
a little slit thingy to put up on your
dash cuz uh otherwise if not then they
wow get her after him biscuits Char
should be here by now hey Billy Jack uh
[__] what did you do Wilson Fisk I hope
they didn't hurt Chola we just talked
about our love of her and that's what
you do you make her great and then
[Music]
you Maya really hasn't done much though
this year
herself she blew up a
tree warning of danger yeah episode
two I really do feel like it needed to
be a longer
season oh kingpin's taking out everybody
she just went there the bird warning
trying to tell you man about danger it's
a good thing we're so invested in Bonnie
she remembers what the bird means
now nice those are always such cool hel
uh like those locked off shots whoa hey
Yep this is Trimm
down I I swear this was supposed to be
10 episodes I feel like it's definit
supposed to be longer you can feel the
and I think that's why there are a 100
writers on
everyone oh
Bonnie
Mommy that look racist there yep wait a
minute they're all not
Bonnie
but none of you guys corrected me so you
guys probably thought the same [__] too
yeah's making sure it's all of us going
down with the ship I thought you were
making a
joke that word Echo yeah it's like you
guys pointed out last
[Music]
episode
oh pretty name and it matches the blood
and that yeah theint that's really David
[Music]
McMan time for the pain to go what
pain where the power is
[Music]
Manifest I like lore that works that way
where you have all the answ ancestors in
[Music]
you
yes oh cool
W it is like one for all kind it's like
the good version of what they did and
what if at the
[Music]
end that's cool the ancestors are your
Infinity Stones yeah gather your
powers
[Music]
cool love in every
Stitch now go beat kingpin's
ass where's Bonnie she's been kidnapped
she's with everybody
else she was just
there that's so pretty the craftsmanship
yeah it's
[Music]
gorgeous Navajo
taco
[Music]
wow this is beautiful the culture
incorporation feels very
natural it's beautiful the sense of
community they lace out is
just there's a real mood to
it you ready to power my
man he's great on res dogs he's like a
spirit guide and also the fact I got
actors from those shows makes me think
they especially trim this show down yeah
no I yeah better than some other shows
have but
yeah Big finale action scene let's go
got to happen got to punch the problem
show up in your suit Echo show up in
that suit we got our emotions out the
way all roads led to this fast
X there's the
X sing it PR boys let's bring them in
boys H
[Applause]
H this looks like the same spot where
they were playing that game I think is
yeah hey wow what an entrance this
suddenly make part of the to be
introduced in this outfit surrounded by
our family with the chalk top people
that is great M celebration oh that is
beautiful I really appreciate that a lot
that was that was unexpected I like that
it wasn't a big Landing it was the
subtle turn
too oh I'm feeling the vibrations yeah
getting really T we're going back to
like feeling from in her
POV go with the Rhythm and just be one
with the
elements and we're so used to going to
here listening to her heartbeat so it's
like that Dr heart with the drums is is
a swell of her
[Music]
emotions I would love her Daredevil just
just show up in the middle of the fight
and just take care of everything like
I've been watching them all day don't
worry I got this
[Applause]
got my gun
bucket I love that the only special
effect in the show is a bird I want my
bir I'm way more invested in this
bird whiplash's bird can stay in the
[Music]
past like the this the show's ability to
capture the culture of present day
whilst also weaving it into the tension
of the situation at hand and making a
mythology and her powers tying into that
I'm saying that like having the culture
representation without it being like
let's just stop to
look is great L biscuit it's about to
get dangerous do you have a gun or a
weapon a
weapon oh I got a weapon I got something
even better what what's biscuits going
to have
911 the full Fury of the Metropolitan
Police
[Music]
Service I mean if Kingpin just gets
defeated again is he just going to show
up in every show to get defeated like
Kang Kang pin it's the thing that
connects all the
universes woof
woof that's
Bonnie which one which one that's her
mom they look Al
like oh he knows well enough that she
would have thrown the contact
[Music]
away he's so terrifying don't throw a
motion to that
Bonnie oh
man I hope he makes it but I bet he
won't I think that guy's going to take
him out it's going to be a mini boss
fight we have to have that
[Music]
like yeah explain the CH
Nation
wow sadistic Man O there's the
confession just in case you forgot the
power of his work through silence and
her reaction and control that was that
was a great
scene crack open a cold one my
dude I don't know how to sign all this
interesting to keep it all on her
perspective
there activate love
yes hashtag him to
death
cool oh my god let's get down to
business whoa no that's cool that's
wicked go
Mador oh damn doing a little bit of a
Thor right now oh well Chula at least
definitely has it but I guess they all
must have some kind of connection to
it none of them have
guns
that's what biscuits
has
biscuit oh my God yes take out the
Cavalry biscuits Monster Jam Monster Jam
[Music]
2024 yeah silence that thing
up
whoa wait what wait what the
wi oh that's got to land
somewhere fireworks the house tonight
definitely not fireworks nope it's just
an explosion in the sky
[Music]
[Applause]
yep oh yeah
[Music]
whoa now twist his
nipples whoa are you healing his eyes
healing
[Music]
him oh now you have to live in my
deth oh the wall that looks like she's
taking him back the painting
[Music]
yeah chill with your trouble
oh angry hurt boy in
[Music]
him
wow whoa she's accepting of this it's to
myself where I
go and what I have to do to get there
no I am not who you want me to
[Music]
be that silhouette Work is
cool what you
do what did you do whoa I'm not a [__]
he's always been such a petulent child
it's so cool to see like the Big Baby
have a tantrum and not like yeah not get
his way can he was about to do that like
Spider-Man into the spiderverse killing
move yeah that big Amazing Spider-Man
number 50 first appearance of ping
pin the greatest compliment I can give
this finale is that it could have been a
hell of a lot worse
sure way better proportion than I
[Music]
expected
butt the butt will be
reserved stay tuned for the
[Music]
butt so wearing the suit helps her get
more in tune because of the threads in
there I don't know if it's physical or
mental but it connects her like maybe
looking at it but it could also
physically and I like kind of leaving
that a little vague actually I think is
kind of nice in a in a time where it's
like you got to know the rules I think
it's actually kind of nice cuz her
grandma made it which connects her and
it visually connects her it could also
physically Bonnie Bonnie greatest
character love Bonnie utilized
throughout properly all that build up
with her I know so much about her
instead of going away she's going to be
going to the barbecue and we're going to
think she's leaving but she's joining
we're going to get the Fast and Furious
ending with the barbecue come on breaks
crack some Coronas why are you ruining
something so I'm hoping that's what
happens Greg and then Scar's gonna show
up with Hulk yes she's gonna
get you brought a lot of criminal
activity here people did die yeah but
she's the protector of tomaha now this
one small town in
Oklahoma what a formal
hug
a that was cool it was the softest we
saw her eyes in the whole
show it feels like a
collaboration thank you Kevin feige
thank you Kevin for authoring all of
this and Bob feige thanks to Stanley for
coming up with
thetion he's a time traveler he's King
the
Conqueror oh there's a skip credits
option oh there's no
post I'm saying no a skip give credit
option means is there is a there
probably a post pay attention John are
the rules sorry which streaming service
are we on if there is no post credit it
just goes to a small box and says now
watch this other [__] cuz you don't care
I want a meeting with all the remaining
heads we need to stabilize this
situation before it viral out of control
oh my
heads race for mayor going to become
mayor yes it turns out most voters want
somebody who is a
fighter there are legitimate problems in
the city right now and the voters want
somebody who understands the pain
they're going through who understands
the frustration they're going through
that's all you there you go man a bare
knuckled brawler would do well in this
race an
outsider mayor Fisk the question that
remains for so many people is that
candidate hting there's no doub wait in
the process but there's still a window
of opportunity that's what the poll is
telling us it could be anybody's race
that is a fantastic way to set up
Thunderbolts will run for
mayor you make him mayor you outlaw
Vigilantes like they do in the comics
all the time and then the Thunderbolts
is uh all that uh I think it's more
Daredevil born again oh I think
Daredevil as well but Thunderbolts is
also like I think it's going to be big
ramifications Young Avengers
Thunderbolts Daredevil I don't think
that's going to have anything to do with
Thunderbolts we're never going to see a
result or follow up I don't think their
new section of their TV show
for Marvel Spotlight are going to
directly
affect Thunderbolts I think X-Men need
to be hated and feared so we need to get
superheroes on the outside born again is
going to be a political thriller King in
the system think so big and scopic and
have more Direction than what they're
currently doing but telling you qu they
should let me write it's not what's
going to happen all set up there born
again and be in there all I know is that
if you want a private jet like well
Wilson Fisk what's really important is
that you start getting your finances in
order now if you learn how to handle
your finances for today then you can
build a fortune for the future and it
all starts with knowing your
bills yeah and this is just Sage advice
as I segue into our sponsor thank you to
Rocket money for sponsoring this video a
brand that I am happy to be partnered
with thrilled to it's fortunately one
that I have been using for quite a while
now prior to ever agreeing to a
partnership with them I was like that
makes for the best kind of synergy
promotion because I can actually talk
about them from my heart here reason
being like many of you guys uh like for
years I am constantly downloading all
kinds of financial apps that I keep
forgetting to use or I don't really find
quite as beneficial rocket money has
been the one the only one I'm not just
saying say it is the only one that I
have been able to consistently use rely
on that has been an absolute game Cher
for me on a very personal note running
real rejects is an absolute privilege
however you know like I stress out about
taxes and it's the beginning of the year
and I'm like I'm trying to be smarter
and get it all done now I already
started like a couple months ago getting
things in order managing real reject
finances while managing my own personal
finances has been an ongoing struggle
and I'm very big on like efficiency and
being organized but clearly wasn't as
good enough as I uh thought I had been
so before rocket money came into my life
I was drowning in subscriptions and
struggling to keep track of my expenses
and as I really wanted to like get
everything in order rocket money came at
the right time for me I was overwhelmed
with subscriptions I didn't even know I
had or had still been subscribed to I
mean do you ever wonder how many
subscriptions you actually pay for have
you ever taken the time to really do it
it could be a little daunting rocket
money helped me see what I was missing
and best part they even cancel those
subscriptions for me with just a simple
tap so with rocket money you can have
all your subscriptions in one place
making it easy to cancel anything
unnecessary without the hassle of
dealing with customer service my is so
annoying plus they'll work on getting
you refunds and negotiate lower bills
saving you up to 20% you just snap a
pick of your bill and let Rocky money
take care of the rest let me just
summarize for you really quick what they
are they're a personal finance app that
findes and cancels unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps lower your bills with over 5
million users and over $500 million in
cancel subscriptions they've already
saved members an average of $720 a year
they've helped save me a little bit more
than that don't waste your hard earn
money on unused subscriptions cancel
them today at Rocket money.com rejects
that's rocket money.com rejects if
you've heard other people talk about
them well use ours Rocky money.com
rejects cuz if you use that promo code
rejects you unlock special benefits and
yes using them is also a great way to
support the channel same time it's just
a great way to support your bank account
cuz I cannot stress enough just how much
this app has changed the game for me
take control of your finances with
rocket money and enjoy Financial Peace
of Mind all righty guys well if you're
listening to Apple Spotify we just
watched uh Echo finale we have not
talked about it at all um now I just
wanted to google before going into this
because I I like this episode I do I
actually I sincerely do I like it I
could feel some of the typical Disney
plus ending pitfalls that it most
certainly fell into certain points and
most importantly I was like I really got
the sense I this is the first time I
could feel I could feel the behind the
scenes in a different way just having an
understanding of [__] that went down COI
my man why every time someone else is
talking just freaking like it is not a
toy every time just freaking well I'm
not talking so so let me just this isn't
making any noise is
it it was bring against go like I'm move
it what if Episode re what if Episode
just talking let me just really adjust
the [__] out of this right
now that's content
[Laughter]
baby you saying there's like little ways
you could adjust it without
let me just grab every part
of we have all the tracks and Co knows
that we can just go in and mute that and
it won't take any extra effort or or
separation or create any potential
confusion editing is the easiest part of
our jobs everyone knows it
oh hands free
anyway
so what are we talking about episode
finale we were getting into what the
original plan for the episodes was
despite how this finale turned out yes
yeah like oh the behind the scenes
experience was like I could feel it of
they so obviously had more in in the can
here and the impression I got was this
really smart conscientious choice I
could feel on the filmmaker's end I I
have to defend it for all we know like
theoretically Eight Episodes the eight
are terrible and they had a trim uh I I
don't know what the reason reasoning was
the the the smart choice I felt of of
them to do was that okay we are being
forced to cut this
down how do we make up for that let's at
least have a consistent tone let's at
least have a consistent mood a
consistent atmosphere
that way we can at least have some sense
of
uniformity by the time we reach the
finale where some of this stuff probably
would have worked a little bit better if
you know things had more time to breathe
or if they had more time to develop
something or dive in and maybe you don't
feel this way maybe you don't maybe
you're like I thought it was great it
was perfect everything was there maybe
you feel that way and that's cool if you
do uh I personally was able to get this
Sense on almost everything that went
down of yeah there probably was more of
a better build to most of these things
that happened and even like fight scene
moments getting
shortened uh certain part but there were
still so many things in here that I was
impressed with the choice when they
wanted to be emotional about it it was
very emotional like the scene with her
mom was great originally Bonnie but then
her
mom what a strange Choice like we're all
connected we're going to change actress
Bonnie showed up I was like no they in
my mind they they they do look I'm not
saying they all look say specifically
those two I feel like they both are very
gentle eyes I I'll I'm going to slightly
give you might be like no they don't
Greg go ahead engage in the comments
helps the video out in my opinion I I
was like no I mean come on I'm I didn't
see their faces that much on screen even
though we just saw the mom in a
flashback earlier in the episode so
whatever clown on me all you want
um I still thought there was great
emotionality there when she Dawns the
suit uh the representation of the chak
to nation in terms of this Festival I
thought was great even the scene when
she confronts Wilson Fisk and and and uh
and the barn and how was in her POV and
and then Wilson Fisk and his memory
core I could still
sense yeah you you could definitely feel
the trimmings though on almost
everything that was happening this
episode felt like it was grabbing pieces
of a lot of threads and I could feel
like it wasn't their fault if that makes
that's in summary it seemed like they
had to go what what can we make count
the most and how do we make this feel
still like a a package is complete
Redemption for biscuits like I feel like
there was like a lot of background
characters that didn't get to become
foreground characters as much as they
would have like some of the Supporting
Cast felt fully fleshed out but some
didn't I feel like they might have been
I definitely noticed the scene of her
like on the motorcycle in completely
different gear than running in the house
and I was like what scene happened
between that like that could have been a
whole day they just like they probably
just lasted longer in some fact showing
up taking the gun letting tension simmer
instead of just cut two running
different clothes and and I think that
made the last episode feel a little you
know lesser but I do like that it didn't
just end with a A Punch Out fully I did
like the visual representation of of the
The Echoes of her ancestry I really
loved the emotional
through line of music and like the way
the sound design blended with her
heartbeat in that scene but then also at
the end scene I really liked what we set
up with a new emotionality in Fisk uh
through how she healed in some way him
maybe we don't know uh I I I thought it
overall worked but it would it worked
more on camera than what it felt like
with behind the camera okay so according
to the reports that we have here and you
know like Disney and feige never affirm
all these things um so they found parts
of the M film material unreleasable due
to various production
challenges uh I couldn't see that was
this film during Co yeah I mean I mean
it's still still happening I have to
imag you know what I mean when it was
like at the height
of protocols um and the episode count
adjustments they were trying to figure
out fix it in four to six episodes they
said let's meet in the middle at
five yeah and they reshot a significant
portion of the series so that's the part
I'm not sure I can't look at at this
foot sometimes you can tell and to me
I'm not sure like where was the re-shoot
I don't know so they seem I feel like
they they seamlessly Blended stuff
whereas like other shows they've done
you're like oh no something went wrong
here or they did not plan this out or
they were forced to make this longer you
know and it it is odd that they would
take especially for one that wants to
honor the Netflix shows that came prior
I think that might have been decided
later I'm wondering how much of this got
R-rated up and how much was filmed in
the beginning not that R rated that's
what I'm wondering you know what I mean
like how much did they add SP TV 14 yeah
so I'm wondering if they decided like
hey we'd like to mature up blank let's
let's have Echo be that Gateway like
later on sure I'm really curious when
that decision was made because I do
think there was maybe some hit Kickback
from Hawkeye and they were like what if
the Kingpin is going to be the Netflix
Kingpin now and then they like Jed up
Echo well they say filmed the material
unreleasable it does make me curious
what that UNR like it's strange to talk
about this one because especially for
our end because we we'll see what's like
like behind the scenes production
problems that you could feel or like
some [__] went down here and I could
tell but I didn't feel it until finale
and I didn't know all these details
until now and for all and for all know
these details were just rumors but it
certainly feels the sense you get is
that certainly seems especially didn't
even know what happened to Henry after
there was clearly stuff caught even from
1 through 4
I was already like there's no way they
can wrap this [__] up in in in five and
there's no way they can flesh out things
they were building up and and put a
proper cap on that or stamp on that and
even to a certain extent like I like the
intention and the choice of the echoing
through the lineage that seemed obvious
it was like I think from epod think from
episode two you're like yeah no the
whole lineage right that's what's
happening and it's all that com through
um and I like the specificity of which
each person represented I didn't pick up
on that I didn't either that was cool
what exactly is like why why are we
focusing on that and it played with the
comic Mythos in a way that felt like it
was very approachable like this doesn't
feel like you're missing out on reading
it but it also if you like this
character you should read it because
there is more in the David ma Joe cada
version so I I do think they noded to
her power set in a fun way that leaves
it open to diving into more without
feeling like oh I'm missing out what was
your character AR John lay it out for
the audience who echo's character Arc
yeah uh you know she learned a bit about
who she actually is she learned to let
go of some of that ingrained rage and
the chip on her shoulder and she learned
how to begin to embrace process and let
go of pain and that is demonstrated in
the ending scene with Kingpin as she
encourages him to try and do the same
because she recognizes herself as part
of an ongoing cycle of violence and uh
hurt and all that stuff yeah it's great
and you know she fights a couple times
too she gets a new prosthetic leg
yeah I still think there was a AR guys
we just had Secret in I mean we didn't
just have it's just well the last bad
show we had
secret the last show we had last was
like month the last bad one what is
was were good ones yeah oh that's right
Loki was after this is funny secret
evasion feels so much longer ago because
of how not great it was yeah time is so
weird with that show that is that is a
thing about this and I like the lately
Marvel the biggest issue about any
Marvel thing to me lately has been the
modularity and the fact that you can now
tell that they are so accustomed to
orchestrating their art in a way that
can be picked apart and reorchestrated
and and again it just I keep using the
word modular because it does feel like
you can just try pull this piece out and
jam another piece in there I think they
might have had a harder time with this
one because they shot on location
because they because they didn't have
like some big CGI real to work with
where they can just manipulate and redo
[__] fil this like oh no we have to work
with the footage we have we have to have
a director have a vision L worked that
way sorry yeah L shoots yeah but that's
the thing and I think that does speak
highly to why this works despite that to
the degree that it does because of all
the things lately that I felt that about
and I felt that about Marvel stuff that
I've liked and disliked like the
Marvel's is super fun but it feels like
it's been you know hacked to pieces and
stuff has been pulled out and jammed in
and all that other stuff and this I
think by having it be so tangible so
ground level and So based on its time
place and location that forces you to be
a bit more considerate and a little less
kind of flippant I get the sense or or a
little less fussy like you have to
commit and give the time it takes to go
out and and get that stuff in a way that
you probably can't when you're just
relying all on green screens and all on
volumes and all on how do we have the
most control over this without making it
as tangible as it could be and and this
I think managed and I and I think it's
also to the credit of especially whoever
was directing and editing these things
like I have to imagine that all those
writer credits probably had to do with
taking the original stuff truncating it
down and and props to them as well like
I feel like this is an example of
something that as you said could have
been way worse and could have felt like
so much more of a hack job and I bet it
was hard to put together but they do
manage to make the most out of what have
better than a lot of the other stuff
I've seen lately is by at least going
what works best here and how can we play
into that in a way that at least sings
immediately during the episode maybe we
can't really clinch the totality of it
all but even so I thought they managed
to bring it I like that they went
against the big battle at the end
because they brought it to a place where
I'm like for the size and scope that
these five episodes can give us I think
that's actually a pretty striking way to
do this and everything they bother to
include is great and I'm and my only
note is just like great go deeper let it
breathe more you know we definitely
talked about the mysticism being
something we were worried about the
entire time and I wasn't bothered by it
I really was impressed that that like
slow Trickle and then episode four
brought it a bit heavier and then five
like it got you know Mystic but it never
felt overbearing yeah and like the wind
they brought in the sound design well
the mysticism isn't for isn't Del the
mysticism isn't in service of a of a
bigger batter punch you know like the
opposite and I it's to it tap into his
Spirit right power yeah I I it's it is a
weird viewing experience I'm going to
keep bringing it back to like especially
for our end yeah as people who have the
camera pointer to us constantly when
we're watching these things and are
giving our opinions in the in the middle
of the the viewing experience and being
aware of production things and yada y y
that we are also factoring in Prior
Marvel viewing experiences to this
admittedly instead of just solely taking
it on what it was like I I I can't I
don't know what the realm is of watching
this without hearing any I mean like you
don't need to this is one of those shows
where the only thing you really need to
see is Hawkeye uh even then they kind of
did
the you have like a basic understanding
of the MCU but you know like but because
we've been watching so much of this we
tend to know how it goes so much to the
point that when the suit shows up you're
like okay when she when's the big fight
going to happen at the carnival and then
bam she's going to show up superhero
Landing in her sou we're going to have a
big pose in the music and the way they
just introduced her like that I was so
surprised by how simple yet more
profound it actually was way more
powerful yeah more there was more weight
to it so I again I got to give it to
them that they knew how to make certain
moments really count and I feel like
they were up against that challenge I
don't know know who the filmmakers are I
can't tell you their names I don't know
what they look like I don't know who
they are that made this this series um
but I I certainly got that
impression that they constantly had to
make that choice how in this episode
what do we make count how do we make it
count I really think they were up
against an editing obstacle here I'm
really curious who the official word of
why the show was so bad was because
years ago we heard unreleasable and then
months ago we heard like they're just
going to can it then we were like o
delayed and so much better than a bunch
of other [__] we've SE not most a lot of
the the worst I could say is that like
at times it's mid you know rushed and it
and it skimps a little on
characterization talk about the show as
a whole the finale is better than a lot
of the finales Disney plus is put out
that's the thing is like and that's the
one we all are iffy on episode 4 was
better than a lot of Disney plus stuff
period hard stop and I kept hearing how
bad this was hard disagree I don't
understand hard disagree yeah yeah like
look guys we get we we've been I can't
tell you what it's been H what's
happened with the amount of times we've
got in [__] and people show up in my you
know you know you're pissing off people
when you're constantly getting like oh
now my patrons are messaging me oh now
the now the now I'm getting people
hitting up on social media about
something I said on YouTube you know
yeah when people cross platforms you
know you pissed them off I believe this
I'm going go over here and that's never
stopped us we'll still be honest about
it so we're to hate or whatever and I
don't give a [__] like I was ready the
part of me was ready to rip into this if
it really was bad and instead I had a
completely different viewing experience
I like like I said it's in terms of like
the episodes It's not like one of my f i
i feel like it got better as it went
this show like four was I felt like the
show just progressively got better as it
went so I would probably stack it
somewhere between like one and two um n
put it above two yeah I put this episode
above two even though I think two this
is definitely a better story and flow is
better moments of weight I liked a lot
yeah it's just like yeah the moments
that worked really worked for me that
visual was so cool and it definitely
felt like David maart which is something
I was looking for too because he's an
artist I I have a wall of his art in my
place you guys haven't seen it but I
have a literal like David Max's one of
my favorite artists in comics it's the
one right behind my door next to the
comic have you seen that seen you must
have seen But I I've got a wall of David
maart so I know that but I mean behind
the door I don't know if you I
investigated every inch I have assessed
but I have a wall of David maart and I
was really looking forward to some of
those style choices he makes like he's a
very visual Storyteller he's a painter
he's a kabuki artist and there was some
of that here in really wonderful ways
like the the handprint is obviously the
most obvious of the mirroring but the
way some of the line work moved felt
like a painting and the way the
mirroring of all them through the echo
felt like different paint pallet colors
and like different like style it was
really cool to see a comic that I think
flows in a really
painted way in a way that feels really
unique translate and I I got a lot out
of that and he was super handson with
this project like I know to the point
where Vincent and alfio's uh book he
wrote is illustrated by David Mack they
became friends through this production
like it's it's he was very Hands-On it
showed for me so from the behind the
scenes statement of of a comic person
this was really delightful yeah you know
I my our job is just to keep being
honest with ourselves that that that's
really what we do it's just be honest
with ourselves and then convey that and
um you know like through the experiences
of many of the Marvel Star Wars uh the
the two main IPS when it comes to
there's been plenty of times like I'm
enjoying a show and then yeah I see on
social media some people are talking
about it or some other videos are a
little now you understand my Rants and
and then what will happen is like
sometimes I don't I wouldn't say it
influences it it sometimes it'll put
something into words of an issue I was
having that I couldn't quite artic
articulate and that articulate just like
I can't articulate the word
articulate articulate uh and and so I
would so sometimes I would see and be
like yes that's what it is and and then
I was then suddenly I'm seeing it a
little bit more because now I'm like oh
now I see how to formulate a and I
thought from everything I was seeing
from ech I'm like okay is that what's
going to happen with me now and it
didn't like I I knew my opinion really
well on this prior I normally do I knew
my opin on this pretty well and I
thought like okay here's where my
agreeance is going to come in with all
them haters and yeah the worst I
personally feel is that at times the
show is mid the times where I feel like
it gets bad is when something is not
breathing well enough but and and the
writing like oh this is a hard show to
judge the writing on when it's it's like
been CH chopped and hacked but they they
let enough important scenes breathe to
where I would times would be like good
writing and the acting was just so
goddamn good the acting I cannot get
over especially for me the Henry guy
where he was acting with his body his
voice and his his ASL I was so
transfixed by all of his acting like all
three of those modes were at 11 Grandma
for me man oh 100% well and that's the
prevailing sense that I am feeling about
this overall is like even if it doesn't
get to fully reach the potential that it
you know posit clearly capable of more
so than a lot of Marvel lately I felt
the care and attention that went into
th% there was a fervor there for sure
yeah and just like the amount of of like
true consideration and especially as
we've touched upon like with the
cultural element Disney itself has
perpetrated so many examples of like oh
here's how to tack this on in a in a
disingenuous way and here it really felt
I liked your point about the powow and
the fact that you're cutting between the
ceremony and also stuff that's happening
in the barn and yeah you're using a set
piece in a way you kind of expect to
raise tension and to use the you know
Lively colors and everything and and all
the noise you know to kind of you know
raise the tension but it doesn't play
out the way you expect it to and it does
create this sort of hypnotic Just moment
where yeah like the plot shit's still
happening but you also get to live in
The Duality of the scene and of the
culture and of the you know Aura the
vibe and it gives it lends this sort of
spiritual just air to the you know
sci-fi [__] that's about to happen in
the barn like and it's one of those
things that I don't think that you could
have made a product as a final you know
product as you know at all the things
that this excels at without that care I
don't think it would have happened and I
feel tremendous amounts of care from all
the craftsmanship on every creative
level we said that in the first episode
a lot too we were we were acknowledging
the film making in it being so strong
like it's clear that it wants to spend
time in this place and and making these
characters and on emble and it's like it
gets like every aim it sets out to
achieve it gets part of the way there at
least and I got nothing against Oklahoma
but this is the most I've ever wanted to
go to Oklahoma like I I just never
thought of it like I'm I travel as much
as I can and I've never been like you
know Oklahoma and now I'm like you know
Oklahoma uh may I briefly please explain
this ending just cuz I think there are
what I wanted you to get to I got a
video production to do so yeah let's go
uh the ending the post credit scam which
is going to be something everybody's
talking about because that's how these
things go they look to the next thing on
the micro scale I think at minimum Greg
is right with this leading into
Daredevil I do think that the new
daredevil show will have something to do
with mayor Fisk Fisk has been mayor in
the comics a number of times he only
recently was dethrown by Luke Cage
currently Luke Cage is mayor in the
comic books and he is working against
fisk's old jurisdiction so basically
he's dealing with a last chm leader and
he's trying to get through all of his
bureaucracy and red tape so in the
current comic books being a vigilante is
illegal being Miss Marvel's illegal
being Spider-Man's illegal anyone wears
mask illegal and there's a a team of her
Heroes that are government very uh
property basically and Hawkeye leads a
team of thunderbolts trying to get that
to be okay and to get you know people on
the side of Heroes again that's I think
the micro I don't think the daril is
going to have all that I'm just saying I
think Daredevil will be about it being
illegal to be a hero and that's starting
to shift things Fisk having power in New
York him getting the strong arm over um
Hell's Kitchen New York City all those
elements I think are the small on the
macro if they go hard this could be
Daredevil Spider-Man 4 Thunderbolts and
leading to X-Men this is 10 foil hat
coin now I gave you a little one this is
big one now this could be I could see
going to Spider-Man definitely factoring
to Spider-Man way more than Thunderbolts
so I think we're getting it Thunderbolts
to be a team that is bad guys that are
not actually that bad that do something
horrendous and realize they messed up
and then they're revealed as as villains
to Heroes I think that'll be an element
there and I think it'd be great to have
in the background New York have a
villain as the leader and the heroes be
seen as villains that way you tie into
those elements so it might not be as
directly as I think you're think I'm
saying but I think setting up the MCU to
have a distrust to Heroes leads to a
world that hates and fears the X-men
Spider-Man 4 I think needs to have
something where the unmasking in
Spider-Man 2 didn't land anything
because by the time we got to Spider-Man
3 they were like he's hunted no he's not
no way home and that's the one thing
about no way home I wish I could change
was it was originally supposed to be a
craven story originally Craven was
supposed to be hunting Spider-Man
because he revealed his identity and
they get him to basically be on the run
I think Spider-Man 4 could be that again
where he's not with the Avengers he
doesn't owe any of them Fisk is Mayor
and this way you could tell that same
story they wanted to but on a smaller
scale finally have the more friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man have Kingpin as
a villain which denafo has been very
vocal about wanting have Daredevil as a
as a compatriot but not in a really big
way so it still stays a Spider-Man movie
and if all of that works and that does
tie in together this is a great way to
reboot the universe overall Captain
America 4 they're doing all these tons
of re-shoot I think that's going to be
basically having the super soldier
element that lands later on into
Thunderbolts set up in a new way and I
think overall having mayor Fisk is how
you do a more Emperor Palpatine Kang
where he is the thread that ties
everything in together he's a character
that's overarching but not in a way that
needs a lot of screen time or a lot of
explanation mayor FIS is I think a
genius move for street level and higher
leading of Secret Wars I mean there's
one thing for sure he's playing mayor
Fisk that's happening they made that
abundantly clear they said mayor 18
times we need someone that fights
someone that's brutal I I fight I'm
brutal I should audition
mayor but I also like the different
emotionality on his face that was
interesting uh yeah it was great uh I
mean there's one thing I'm really happy
about is just like Vincent and arrio
they it's way better here than it was in
hongi that's for
sure and and I and the the ending they
gave him is a very interesting Direction
because it wasn't like he just gets his
ass whooped and then
he do something it's like he kind of
runs away there's there's a an
opportunity to face the trauma
and yeah it's like that was so scary for
him yeah that he had to get away from
her and that's that's a reasonable cause
for him to not yeah just come back and
be like well I'm going to kill you again
when I regroup you know like like she
can take me out a different way entirely
so I'm not even going to mess with her
and now he goes back to New York and
he's like I'm a broken wounded animal
like an animal in a corner is the
scariest thing now he is again and that
pain that he holds on to is one of the
things that allows him to propel to the
heights that he does you know like some
people it's that that age-old thing
about like tortured artists you know
feeling like they need their pain in
order to be a great
artist or a great
murderer are you torturing John for his
art I know I'm saying oh he needs the
pain I can't I'm just trying to have
I'll happily be painfree I'm trying to
get the the I'll happily shed
the tortured artist line I mean I love
everything great Optimist Prime over
here Autobots roll out last week we made
fun of Co or last episode we made fun of
coy now it's John's turn if I could be
happy I
would I'm
John I don't think he's e a deep void of
sadness exists within and I keep
throwing stuff into it and I just did
you know it it Chucks some things out it
swallows some things
up deal with your pain man no I got and
he's going to La apartment pain and I
go pain I logically understand the
the part of like I can assess it I can
acknowledge it over there you go this is
therapy talk at the real rejects after
dark yeah yeah like taboo midnight taboo
like the Tom Hardy Show no no oh like
the concept of something being taboo no
the game the game there's a game oh the
face nope that's not the game oh there's
a game called taboo I think it's got a
little face little guy and he's like
he's like don't say it taboo is that not
the game oh oh is that is the cover Oh I
thought you were saying like there's a
no all right guys what' you think about
Ekko what do you think about taboo leave
your thoughts down below rapper in the
black are you excited to see Ekko join
Avengers Secret Wars now insane Powers
AR this one they did not really demonstr
just going to do he didn't get a grenade
in the face defeat Dr Doom she's gonna
be like let's look at your trauma yeah
can't hear your face but I'll heal your
traa let's go to Platform 9 and three
quarters and talk this out she did learn
quiddit yeah it's true she's powerful
I'm excited but yeah but I believe her
is still like a street level with some
embellishments yeah they didn't go like
big freaking finale fight scene here
like it could have been that it could
I'm glad it wasn't I could see her in
Daredevil Netflix esque easy when it
subtly brings in the idea of like faith
healer you know oh but people are still
going to do like overpowered oh
guaranteed Mary Sue she learned how to
heal quickly that's not real how' she
get her powers she was born yep that is
actually yeah what they're telling that
is what they're telling
but you know she had to unlock them over
time and be empowered to understand what
they even mean but how but she didn't do
anything to unlock them training Montage
Montage there was nothing train Montage
was her life she didn't really do
anything to unlock them that's she
should have gone to
Cartage like when
Denzel Denzel why I say Denzel training
Daredevil oh yeah hey Daredevil take I
was watching some listen video last late
last night about like how uh Denzel and
Tarantino didn't get along for many
years and then they had to squash their
and apparently Denzel has been outspoken
about it and I was like CU I first
thought it was just some like stupid
gossip thing and then and then I was
like oh what this like a real thing so
it's kind of been on my mind like oh
damn no wonder we never got Denzel and
Tarantino work together yeah Vendetta is
it for the obvious reason or another
reason I'd assume no very OB a very
different reason oh okay yeah okay
anyway get to Googling guys thank you to
Rocket money for sponsoring this video
thank you to Denzel for squashing the
beef of Tarantino and for being awesome
um do you guys think that uh mayor Fisk
is going to uh affect Avengers Secret
Wars like how Koy is predicting Hey
listen with the patreon of the day shout
out FV Doran fev Doran it is
2024 we have entered the year of fev's
shout out
and dude I know what your resolution is
going to be it is to run
across nude on live television for WW
whatever the initial is now ww wrestling
yes you are going to do it while Dwayne
The Rock Johnson's out there and he's
like I'm able to multitask I can do
Moana and make a TV show and promote all
that while still doing wrestling
fulltime cuz I don't sleep and then bam
you just run across naked cheeks
flapping flapping and all right in front
of him and then what does he do he gives
you the smack down on your bottom and
he's like and that's why I'm here to
give you all the best ass
smacking of a real cand of them all yeah
real I don't care what your name is turn
that ass to the people so fev man you
are going to be um just the most popular
name in all of wrestling once people
identify like who's that jackass running
on television F Doran patron of the real
reject who's that ass running across
don't worry we're going to protect you
Bible censorship style you're going to
run across with a leaf making sure it's
stays
on you are covered industrial grade glue
cuz a but you can change shape size
whatever you know that is kind of
permanent situation in the centerpiece
so we will cover that with a leaf not
open you up to
judgment anyway FB we' love you
and we really do love you is evidenced
by this 2024 ends up being a Immaculate
year for you man you're a great guy with
a huge slong it's going to be really
hard to hide with those giant oak leaves
yeah you're going to a leaf
blower oh buddy FL you nutty dog you put
that thing away FL stop it seriously
you're going to get us demonetized piece
of [__] what are you doing you [__]
you're being a jerk you're being a jerk
F anyway F love you buddy we'll talk to
you soon
peace